et on parle à présent pour refermer
cette émission refermer cette page port
du Dakar on le disait on a Jean-Pierre
Garcin qui est avec nous copilote
originaire de Montesson et qui a terminé
16e au côté du pilote chinois et
goyuzang pour cette donc 45e 45e édition
du Dakar vous avez terminé à plus de 17h
du vainqueur et Qatari Nasser à la tia
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait de cette
16e place non c'était pas l'objectif on
n'est pas satisfait mais bon après faut
se contenter malheureusement c'est un
Dakar très très dur et on a eu un petit
souci le deuxième jour on perd du 3
heures sur un petit choc avec une un
rocher qui a traversé la route c'est les
je pense que c'est 7h c'est pas 17h 17h
ça fait beaucoup
nickel non non après c'était un Dakar
difficile qui a duré 14 jours donc deux
jours de plus que l'année dernière la
météo n'a pas été clémente on a subi le
froid la pluie pendant la moitié du pue
de la moitié du rallye voilà mais bon
globalement non non on est quand même
content faut pas exagérer quoi déjà on
est content de rentrer c'est déjà la
première chose et puis après bah on va
rapidement penser au prochain ça c'est
la dur loi du Dakar c'est que on a à
peine un mois de se dire ah je sais pas
si je vais retourner et tout et puis
après de toute façon c'est qu'on y
retournera si on a envie bien sûr bon et
là c'est un peu ce que je me pose comme
question mais je pense que j'y
retournerai encore vous étiez venu en
décembre ici en parler donc la 16e on
est pas très loin l'objectif
c'est les écarts sont très serrés quoi
il y a plus trop de différence il y a
plus de il y a plus d'arrêt les voitures
tombent plus en panne enfin mon moi je
suis pas sorti de la voiture à part en
cas de choc puis on a fait deux
crevaisons je suis jamais sorti de la
voiture avant sans sablé et tout
maintenant les voitures sont tellement
performantes qui se passent plus tout ça
au moins devant quoi derrière bien sûr
c'est difficile donc les écarts sont
très très petits entre tous le 15e doit
être à 5 minutes devant nous le 17e à 5
minutes derrière nous donc le premier à
7 heures pas 17h pardon désolé c'est
normal on a rajouté 10h maintenant 7h
c'est déjà très très bien le premier
c'est c'est encore autre chose
de la discipline lequel le plus dur de
se rallye selon vous ah le moment le
plus dur pour nous je pense que les
étapes 5 et 6 ont été très dur parce que
c'est cette étape d'herbe ce qu'on
appelle nous de l'herbe à chameau c'est
du sable avec de la végétation et puis
des boss des boss des boss c'est pas
vraiment des dunes et là on tape on tape
on tape et c'était des longues étapes
qui faisaient genre 400 km les deux
c'était dur là franchement c'était dur
physiquement on était tous exténués
parce qu'on prend des coups maintenant
c'est la limite c'est plus la voiture
c'est voiture sont très solides c'est
notre corps toute la journée alors le
pilote il a encore le volant pour cette
année nous on a rien on est comme ça
puis ou comme ça et puis on prend des
chocs quoi voilà quoi donc c'est un peu
c'est un peu chaud ces deux étapes
heureusement à la l'étape 8 après on
avait une journée de repos et après
c'est reparti et après c'était plus je
dirais pas plus facile mais moins
contraignant physiquement c'est un petit
peu piéger le parcours en Arabie
Saoudite très piégeux parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de variétés de terrain et la
difficulté cette année c'est qu'ils
avaient un peu augmenté le niveau de
difficulté ce que tout le monde s'était
plein en 2022 donc
personne se plaindra prochaine c'est sûr
et certain mais bon ils vont garder le
standard parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
fait des boralies parce que si c'est
trop facile bon bah les gens s'en
souviennent plus en général on se
souvient des choses qui sont difficiles
c'est vrai que celui-là on s'en
souviendra c'est le plus difficile des
trois qu'on vient faire en Arabie
Saoudite et je pense qu'il on se
standard quoi et la météo elle était
comment très mauvaise très mauvaise du
froid de la pluie on a eu de la chance
on a passé 4-5 jours avant le rallye au
bord de la mer là il faisait beau mais
dès qu'on est parti la pluie nous a
suivi on a eu deux trois belles journées
dans les petits quarter donc
complètement dans le sud le long de la
frontière de l'Oman et puis mais après
tout le reste on est remonté héro de la
pluie on a fini dans la boue quoi c'est
truc
sur le Dakar en Arabie Saoudite en
Arabie Saoudite oui autant que ça oui
oui on a vu des fois des petits épisodes
plus vieux mais pas beaucoup là il y a
on a vu des images nous on est de la
chance parce que il y a une étape où les
les souhaites ce qu'ils appellent les
Oued on montait son il y a une crue on
nous on était on était devant on n'a pas
vu ça mais derrière les concurrents ont
été arrêtés quoi ils ont été forcés de
de stopper la spéciale et tout non non
c'était vraiment depuis diluvienne quoi
c'est
changement climatique on va dire non
chose importante c'était votre première
collaboration avec le pilote un chinois
je disais gros comment ça s'est déroulé
cette couleur la surprise un petit peu
c'est quand même qu'elle avait pas
appris grand chose en anglais mais après
il y avait un traducteur pour assurer
traducteur n'était pas dans la voiture
bien sûr le traducteur le soir mais non
mais sinon après dans la communication
même dans la voiture tant qu'on a pas de
cas particulier ça se passe bien il
suffit pas beaucoup de mots j'ai compris
très rapidement que j'avais pas appris
grand chose parce qu'il m'avait demandé
de bien faire des gestes donc c'est bon
voilà mais au bout de trois quatre jours
ça a été non non c'est juste qu'on a des
problèmes c'est quand on se perd mais
comme je disais on se perd de moins en
moins sur le Dakar ou qu'on ait des
problèmes techniques quoi voilà donc
mais non globalement ça a été ça a été
c'est un jeune qui est très talentueux
je pense qu'il va progresser il a 38 ans
il a le Dakar c'est un truc où c'est que
son troisième Dakar il faut beaucoup
d'expérience tout le monde le dit donc
il faut attendre un petit peu dans
quatre cinq ans il sera bien voilà
de l'expérience 24e Dakar ce que vous
allez repartir l'année prochaine oui
l'année prochaine j'ai dit non à ma
femme en rentrant
jusqu'à ce soir maintenant elle aura la
révélation ce soir mais qu'est-ce qui
vous pousse à continuer pourquoi il
repartir c'est tout moi c'est de la
passion c'est de la passion voilà je
vois pas non non je me dis on va trouver
quelque chose je suis pas inquiet quoi
avec au lieu de Zango avec un autre
pilote je sais pas non je peux moi
j'aimerais bien avoir
l'expérience que j'ai j'aimerais bien la
donner c'était difficile à cause de la
barrière du langage
j'en ai donné un petit peu mais c'était
difficile donc essayer de trouver un
jeune pilote talentueux qui veut
participer à son premier au deuxième
Dakar ça ça me plairait parce que j'ai
quand même beaucoup de choses à leur
apprendre et c'est normal quoi donc
voilà redonner un peu de
que j'ai acquis elle redonné un jeune ça
serait bien quoi bien merci Jean-Pierre
Garcia
on vous suivra bien sûr les prochaines
il y avait un autre évidence qui était
engagé sur ce Jean-Pierre trugaud
termine à 50e place de la course sur NDA
rallye sport comme quoi les Jean-Pierre
réussissent bien sur le Dakar
Jean-Pierre réussi ce bien que leur chat
peut-être un une réaction qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur une telle
expérience aventurière on parle des
derniers aventuriers quand on parle des
skippers sur le Vendée Globe aussi des
pilotes sur le sur le Dakar oui c'est
également un sacré engagement physique
en effet et puis et puis aussi une bonne
connaissance mécanique et puis de la
conduite et c'est toujours
impressionnant ce genre de ce genre
d'épreuve
passion c'est une belle ça reste une
belle aventure humaine quoi franchement
voilà même